Not sure if you're able to answer this. My oncologist has me on pitcrate 200 milligrams. I'm having lots of edema.
She put me on increased water pill. We asked if she would consider lowering the chemo dose because it seems to be working.
But maybe a little lower dose would do the same without as many side effects. One of your thoughts the nurse said.
She wouldn't change dose into without a scan in another way. Can we argue with her or just do what they say for waiting for a say to our test, which is a circulating tumor cell.
Just to come back also are those tests pretty accurate compared to two markers.
Well, they're just totally different than two markers, but it's just another test to look at things.
Yeah, unfortunately, the personalized medicine with your oncologist is kind of just doesn't exist very often anymore.
And it's part it's really honestly probably, you know, maybe 75% because they are covering their butt as far as a lawsuit or 25% that they just are not maybe very technical.
No, but it's it's really hard to get personalized care where you can say, hey, can we drop this down a little bit.
I would just ask or try to ask and see what they say. I mean, she might have a valid reason to say no.
I want to keep you on this. You're doing well. It's deal with the symptoms. She might have, you know, kind of giving you a bunch of loading to try to keep you on that to keep her tail covered.
So she doesn't get in trouble with her boss. It's just the doctors don't control things anymore.
They're just pawns in the whole grand scheme of big form, unfortunately.